stranger things is back with a massive
slice of 80s nostalgia and a new
supernatural threat to keep the
residents of Hawkins on their toes
yippee-ki-yay lovers it's Jan here and
today I'm delving into the second season
of Netflix's critically acclaimed sci-fi
horror series to discuss the ending and
some clues about what it means for
season 3 I'm also starting my stranger
things giveaway so for your chance to
win a Funko pop of your favourite
stranger things character just make sure
you're a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video with your thoughts about
the show spoiler alert
obviously I'm discussing the finale of
season 2 plus other episodes from the
first two seasons of stranger things so
take care if you're not all caught up
remember back in season 1 where Mike
asked 11 to go to his schools and you'll
dance the snowball well at the end of
season 2 a year later in the show
storyline the pair finally made it there
but this is Hawkins Indiana and stranger
things is getting at least a 3rd and 4th
season so we know that things won't be
all happily ever after for our AV Club
friends and to prove just that as the
camera moves out of the school and into
its parking lot it starts to rotate
taking us back to the upside-down and we
see the shadow monster looming over the
school so why is the shadow monster back
at the very end I mean didn't 11 just
close the interdimensional gateway and
didn't Joyce just drive the thing
inhabiting wills body out of him well
yes but that victory is just a temporary
one as stranger things creators the
differe brothers specifically said that
the shadow monster will carry over
beyond season 2 becoming a main villain
of sorts for the series as a whole let's
look then at how our heroes defeated the
extra-dimensional Big Bad this season
and how their actions leave things open
for the monsters return in season 3
simulator season 1 the season 2 finale
finds 11 battling the show's monster
wants more to save her friends Elle's
role this time is to close the
interdimensional gateway which is a
cathartic experience for her and she
feels responsible for having opened it
in the first place obviously closing the
gate requires an incredible amount of
exertion on Elle's part we already know
that using her powers drains her for
example she collapsed after taking out
the agents pursuing her and her friends
at Hawkins middle school last season
thankfully her journey away from Hawkins
to meet her mother this season
also let her to Kali aka ate another
young survivor of dr. Brenner's
experiments and she taught L to control
her powers by channeling her anger about
events from her past given Elle's
treatment at the hands of Rena or Papa
as she calls him she certainly has a lot
to work with on that score still if she
tries to close the gate you can see the
energy she summons as she even levitates
and the physical toll on her is such
that she bleeds from both nostrils but
closing the gate isn't just about
shutting down an actual portal to the
upside down and saving her friends so
what else does it mean well think back
to when Carly tried to persuade al to
stay with her
so they could use their gifts against
all the people who'd hurt them in that
moment Carly used her powers on Al to
make her see an apparition of dr.
brenner
who told el that you have to confront
your pain you have a wound a terrible
wound and it's festering and it will
grow spread and eventually it will kill
you figuratively speaking then the gate
el closes is also the wound she has to
repair in order to heal herself of the
emotional and physical pain she had jaw
did hawkins lab and of the guilt she
feels for unintentionally and indirectly
causing current events and like an
especially bad wound the gate and the
surrounding area are red and angry
looking they pulsate and something nasty
seeps out but as soon as the gate or
wound is closed the scene is flooded
with blue tinged light a visual sign
that the characters have moved from
danger and rage to calmness and healings
however that won't be the end for our
chaos causing creature as we see the
outline of the shadow monster behind the
gate before L closes it and that
monstrous smokey tendrils
to try and stop al from doing her job
seemed to be forced back into the upside
down rather than be destroyed 11 does
the heavy lifting so to speak in closing
the portal but the a/v Club gang are
instrumental in clearing the path for
her to reach the gate went along with
Max and Steve they enter the tunnels and
set the main hub area on fire
drawing the demo dogs away something
interesting happens here though when
Dustin gets sprayed by a huge
flower-like creature in the tunnels he's
wearing a mask at the time but complains
the spray goes in his mouth something
similar happened to hopper and
earlier episode when he was sprayed and
trapped by the vines after breaking into
the tunnels
both Dustin and hopper seemed healthy at
the end of the season but I wonder if
there could be an incubation period for
an infection that may affect them next
season when will was recovered from the
upside down in season 1 II had a huge
tendril in his mouth which presumably
infected him with a slug he coughed up
later I don't think either Dustin or
hopper will be affected in the same way
as will was but the hivemind monster
already showed how it spreads itself and
operates and it's ominous that at least
two more characters have potentially
been exposed to its influence and let's
not forget there's always that Demma dog
that Destin and Steve put into the
fridge for safekeeping will of course
plays a bigger role this season than
last as it becomes a host body for the
shadow monster at the end of the third
episode Mike believes that will has
gained the power of true sight with the
ability to see what the shadow monster
is planning Mike sees this as a way for
the gang to spy on the evil entity
however as we see later in the spy
episode it's the shadow monster who uses
will to spy on Hawkins residents and
manipulate events setting a trap for the
soldiers in the tunnels the group
eventually understands that what's
inside will is part of a hive mind which
Destin likens to the mind flayer in
Dungeons & Dragons mind flayers the evil
creatures would tend to collect heads
that feed on their victims and also
enslave others with telepathic mind-meld
type powers mind flayers themselves are
also guided by a central elder brain
which in stranger things seems to be the
shadow monster itself and mind flayers
also reproduce via tadpoles
the end up implanted into humanoid
beings where they feed on the subjects
brain and eventually take its place in
stranger things will coughed up the
slug-like creature at the end of the
first season and the way he slowly loses
his memory and identity to the shadow
monster in season two parallels the idea
of mind flayer tadpoles slowly eating
humanoid brains Joyce understands that
this entity inside will is like a virus
and so she sets about exercising this
demon like spirit from Will's body by
tying him up in front of a fire and
electric heaters this works and we see
the shadow monster leave Will's body and
escape out of the cabin into the night
sky this is a victory for Joyce in
saving her son
again from the evil behind the
upside-down however it hasn't
necessarily been killed just temporarily
banished and is waiting to return so did
you enjoy stranger things season 2 and
do you have any theories about the
ending or anything else from the season
or perhaps you've got a theory about
season 3 let me know what you think in
the comments below and also make sure
you subscribe for a chance to win my
stranger things giveaway and
congratulations to the winner of my
Blade Runner 2049 giveaway who's on
screen now if that's you make sure you
contact me so I can get your details to
send you the prize if you liked this I
really appreciate you hitting that like
button plus you can check out more
videos here I'll be posting new stranger
things and Thor Ragnarok videos shortly
so turn your notifications arm for
flicks in the city to get them as soon
as they're ready thanks for watching and
see you next time
u PK movie lovers